I'm a support of the Palestinians so I'm
used to it yeah well I'm hope your
beeper doesn't go off the thing is is
that did you just say I should die you
should not did you just say I should be
killed the prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tells us that our books will be given
and every little atom weight of Good
Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masjid I
never had the money to build a Masid
Allah you helped you gave towards it and
Allah gives you the reward of as if
you've built it donate now guys and do
not delay and share the video for extra
rewards brothers and sisters and dear
friends the Zionist entity as you guys
know um they feel you know entitled
Untouchable God's chosen satanic people
these zionists that's what they are
that's what they are and the whole world
has seen them for their reality and this
confidence is going to cause them to
have their great fall down that's what's
going to happen because anyone want this
confidence and thinking you Untouchable
and no one can touch you and this Fairy
Land thing of you know you're God's
chosen you was God's chosen people you
were you were God's chosen people so
this arrogance and this racism you can
see it doesn't stop it stops it doesn't
stop anywhere you know on live TV Matan
is actually being threatened by these
Israeli zionists let's hear for
ourselves if you don't want to be called
Nazis stop
doing anite more than El's table and
people sit there no by me I never called
you an anite I mean I'm not saying her
saying I I'm a support of the
Palestinians so I'm used to it well I'm
hope your beeper doesn't go off the
thing is is that did you say I should
die you should not did you just say I
should be killed no I did not say that
did your say I should on live TV I said
guys let me let me just stop said
you of the
Palestinian guys let me Palestinian are
you no
of apiz are you racist personing
violence against Ry Ry disg that is
completely apologize have first block
say the Muslim gu should be blown up I
apologize on apologize don't say then I
apologize you literally I thought you
said Hamas I you didn't think I said
Hamas I said I supported Palestinian
right why because what's funny is Rudy
Giuliani said this yesterday so you're a
great guest to be here to defend Rudy
julani ENT today and so at this point
this is what we're in now this is
America in what I will say forget the
racism I should die I didn't say that
you what does beeper mean don't give me
your F you should why did you say my be
what what did you mean by the Beeper
what did you mean by the be no you
didn't you said I hope your beeper
doesn't go off at least have the guts to
support your racist sorry bring back
this this is why this is why yesterday's
rally was disgusting don't call us Nazis
but I'm going to threaten the brown guys
a terrorist and kill him because I
didn't ever say Donald Trump was Hitler
but do you know who sat on a sta stood
on a stage yesterday and said I want to
come to the Nazi rally I don't have to
make up words and call you something
you're saying it for yourself and what
you just said right apologize but I will
tell you I don't accept that apology and
you didn't even say it to me that was
disgusting but I can be offended when
you don't even say it to me I'm not
Puerto Rican but I was offended by what
he said you can't make this stuff up I
you cannot make this stuff up yeah they
are claiming to be God's chosen people
and Allah God Almighty is showing us
with their own mouths on video footage
with their own hands the atrocities that
they are committing and for 20 years the
year the the war on terror was what that
we Muslims have these beliefs we are the
ones that are against you know we want
to kill infidels where we find them it
was us we were the apparently the ones
where our religion apparently tells and
there is not a single text close to the
Old Testament to tell you directly which
is quot benjam lahu about am what AM
doesn't do direct Commandments of
killing men women children donkeys
babies babies yes nothing like that in
Islam but we were the apparent ones the
Western world is waking up everybody is
waking up their time is up Zionist lies
their propaganda funding the
islamophobia industry it's all up you
know why because they are now so
confident these God's chosen satanic
people are now so confident that they
are outright on CNN can tell a
journalist like M Hassan that hope your
beeper doesn't go off with confidence
you know why because they think they
Untouchable this is why it's going to be
their demise their confidence is going
to be their demise you heard it for
yourself brother sisters and
alhamdulillah brother sister that's
nothing else to be said we're just going
to carry
on excuse me we're just going to carry
on let him talk I don't know who said
this but maybe
remind me but when your enemy is making
a fool of themsel you just let them talk
you know and in this case if your enemy
is perpetrating acts of violence and
genocide you let them talk and all you
do is just screen record like us do a
reaction video and show it to the entire
globe and the entire world that's what
we want to bring to your
attention Islam net is establishing a
Masid and a community center if you
donate to build this Masjid Allah will
in build a house for you in Jenna with
bricks of gold and silver every person
who prays in this Masid every child that
memorizing the Quran you will insh share
in that reward donate now guys and do
not delay
[Music]